majority of people here aren't being
violent but there are some
who are now undertaking activities that
certainly
would be described as otherwise i'm
actually watching a couple of people
scale the walls of the capital
at the moment using some sort of rope
climbing up
and also i should say dermot there are
people here in body armor with helmets
on
uh you know people who come to a
peaceful protest dressed in body armor
uh aren't necessarily expecting it to be
peaceful or
perhaps even to be peaceful themselves
there's been a lot of people
today that i've spoken to in ballistic
type vest and approaching them
i've asked a few of them if they wanted
to do an interview and they don't
actually want to talk to me
on camera or answer questions about why
they're dressed the way they're dressed
but certainly uh there are extremist
groups on both sides i should say
uh who are known for being violent uh
at events like this and we're hearing
reports as well
that there have been some injuries and
an unconfirmed report
of someone being shot in the capitol
building area but we haven't had that
confirmed
that is an unconfirmed report at the
moment dermott